Sauce Kevin's here playing one of the deadliest games
ever created. So deadly,
in fact that I needed balloon Kevin to act as a proxy for
me, real Kevin I'm real Kevin,
the game is Russian roulette.
You probably already know how Russian roulette is played. Traditionally,
a single round is put in a revolver that holds six cartridges.
The cylinder is spun,
so that it's impossible to know which chamber will be fired.
You pull the trigger and there's a five out of six chance
that you are safe and a one out of six chance that it goes really
badly for you.
I've inserted a single needle into each dart.
So that in our version of this game,
it's going to go very badly for poor balloon Kevin,
and that's dangerous and unsafe.
This whole thing is dangerous and unsafe and against the terms of service for
every site on the internet. Thankfully,
Russian roulette is mostly used in movies as a dramatic device,
and I'm using it as a dramatic way to analyze probability.
The important part is that you never do any of this
ever. Okay. Okay.
I want to figure out the best way to survive this notoriously
fatal game. So if balloon,
Kevin plays a standard game of Russian roulette,
he has one in six odds of permanently deflating his dome.
There's about an 83% chance that my rubbery little clone wins
and a 17% chance he loses forever.
And that's that. So here we go. It's time to test your luck balloon.
Kevin.
[Inaudible].
Let's make this scenario a little more complex.
Let's say that there are two balloon bursting missiles inside
six chambers with two possible spherical air sex splattering
darts that have been placed next to each other. Adjacent.
There's a two out of three chance that my air headed doppelganger survives on a
random poll of the toy. So do you like your chances?
Boy, you think that Sharpie mustache is better than the real deal?
Well, let's see a fate is on your side.
The two out of three survival chance comes through.
So it's onto the next round.
My gaseous twin has had a bit too easy of a chance up until
now. The survival math has been very, very straightforward,
had no active role in deciding his own fate.
So let's give him something to think about for round two.
I'm going to give him a choice and place the life odds and his
pipe cleaner hands. The choice is this.
Now he's managed to survive one round of the game.
Does he want to spin the cylinder before playing again?
Or does he just play and hope for the best?
The big question is,
is it better for him to randomize the cylinder or continue
playing with its current configuration? Well,
answer the question, punk,
what's it going to be a blue to be wearing balloon buffoon,
given that there are two adjacent cartridges in there and the toy has been
fired once already.
Does it even matter mathematically whether air Kevin spins or
not, let's find out the first option spinning.
It's the same scenario with the same math.
You're basically recreating round ones, odds,
which we know give you a two out of three chance of survival.
So not really a whole lot to consider there,
but if you don't spend, you know, something else,
the toy he has just been fired on one of the empty chambers,
which is how balloon Kevin survived to get to round two and a
little logic reveals the math of whether to spin or not spin.
Think about the positioning.
There are four possible empty chambers and only one of them
is directly before the two cartridges,
which means there's a 75% chance that round two's trigger pull
is on another empty chamber.
And just a 25% chance that this balloon is about to go by
boom, by not spinning balloon.
Kevin has earned himself about eight more percentage points of
survivability.
And it's such a straightforward probability calculation because we know
that the darts are adjacent.
If they were just randomly placed in the chamber, then
things change.
Here's how there are 15 possible positions for two
darts. Randomly arranged in six chambers.
Six of them are adjacent. So darts would be in one and two,
two and three, three and four, four and five, five and six,
all the way to six and one,
there are six more ways that there can be a single space between the darts.
So one and three, two and six, one in five, four and six,
three and five, two and four. Finally,
there are just three ways that darts can be opposite. One another one in four,
three and six and two and five.
If balloon even survives the first round.
And he doesn't know whether the darts are next to each other or spread out,
does he want his second shot with a spin or with no
spin? We know that we have a 75% chance on surviving those six
adjacent positions for the cylinders that have darts one space apart,
two of the four empty positions come before an empty and two of the four come
before a dart. So that's 50%
and it's the same for the opposite darts.
Our overall safety probability here is a calculation of those
weighted probabilities.
And it goes a little something like this six over 15 times three,
over four plus six, over 15 times two, over four plus three,
over 15 times two over four,
three over 10 plus one over five plus one over 10 equals three over five.
I not spinning here. We have a 60% chance of survival.
They're two 66.6, 7% to over three.
When we do spin.
When we know the darts are adjacent,
we can gain 8% survivability.
When we know they're random,
we can avoid losing about 7%.
It's not some magic solution that allows balloon Kevin to survive.
What's probably humanity's most deadly game doing the
math. Doesn't unveil a secret way to win 80%.
Of the time. It just doesn't work that way.
It could get ya 8% and
8% pretty insignificant. Isn't it?
No,
it's not consider this 0.1% of
DNA is responsible for all the differences you see amongst humans.
And only 1.3% separate us from chimps.
1984 was the last us presidential election.
With more than an 8% popular vote gap.
Improving road safety by 8% would save
96,000 lives per year.
A $1,000 investment growing at 8% compounded annually
doubles in just nine years.
And ultimately if you're an incredibly attractive balloon with
nice big googly eyes, a perfectly formed cotton ball,
nose,
and surprisingly muscular pipe cleaner arms that finds itself
locked in a life or game of chance.
You'll take any advantage you can get to avoid being popped and as
always, thanks for watching.
Hey,
if you want to continue exploring Russian roulette probability for yourself and
use your beautiful balloon head to learn how to think.
brilliant.org has a challenge all about it too. In fact,
as part of their perplexing probability course,
brilliant is great for Vsauce two Watchers like you,
because it's an entire platform based on learning math and science.
By having fun with them,
they're interactive puzzles allow you to expose misconceptions and help you
learn to think by playing perplexing.
Probability is just one of the 60 plus courses on brilliant
that teach you by walking you through puzzles and guiding you and figuring out
the solutions. If you haven't checked it out yet,
I highly recommend doing so.
Just head on over to brilliant.org/vsauce two and sign up
for free.
And the first 200 people get 20% off an annual premium
subscription. So that's a wonderful deal though.
Check it out, enjoy thinking. I.
Need a new balloon, Kevin.
Thanks for watching.
I worked really well. Oh my God.